jared's having a tough time like he had
in miami like he had
yesterday at any point during those
games do you consider
putting him on the bench if not for a
series or the rest of the game
you know uh if i thought it was going to
be the best thing to just take a deep
breath and step away
then i'd say you know maybe but not in
either of those situations because both
of those reflected
you know kind of having an opportunity
where there was enough plays made to get
back
in it um you know dolphins game maybe a
little bit different but i thought it
was important to be able to play through
some of those things
learn from it especially just based on
some of the things that they were
activating defensively
that's sean mcvay yesterday when he was
asked a fairly straightforward question
if he considered benching jared goff and
you know if you've got a franchise
quarterback
that's the kind of question even if
you're sean mcvay and you're great with
the media and you're not like bill
belichick who would scoff and roll his
eyes and say on to cincinnati
you make quick work of that question
that answer went on
a lot longer than what we showed you i
was stunned shireen that it wasn't a
no he's our franchise guy i'm not going
to bench our franchise guy we're going
to work through these issues and try to
get better that should have been the end
of it
yeah very well should have been mike and
it wasn't and
it does make you wonder about jared
goff's future and the way he's playing
the way he's turning the ball over this
season
he just has not been consistently good
for the team he's had stretches
but not enough consistently to make you
think this is a super bowl
championship team yeah uh that's for
sure
and uh you know if if it wasn't for
carson wentz
there'd be a lot more scrutiny on
whether or not jared goff is really
delivering on the promise that made him
the first overall pick in 2016. all
right
re-watch time 49ers upsetting the rams
completing the sweep
kyle shanahan getting the better of sean
mcvay twice and
it's these two coaches who represented
the nfc in each of the last two super
bowls
best player on the field shireen after
you took a closer look at the game
it almost feels like chuck hallish right
well you know chuck halley is the only
def oh the only
player on a losing team to win super
bowl mvp award and of course he did it
way back when we were when we were young
from
is he really the one i grew up in went
to warwick high school
the uh the claim to fame the only
mvp ever ever super bowl mvp from the
losing team chuck hallie of wheeling
west virginia yes
i'm sorry i'm stunned well and
disappointed that you didn't know that
yeah i should have known that darn it um
but aaron donald is a lot like chuck
cali in that he was on the losing side
of this but it was not his fault and i
think his performance mike
on sunday shows two things one it shows
why he is going to win defensive player
of the year yet again
they might as well just rename the
trophy the aaron donald defensive player
of the year award
already i would say the greatest at his
position
in nfl history if he's not the greatest
he's definitely in the top two or three
he's right there
for that but it also shows why he is not
as the best player in the nfl is not
going to win the nf mvp award because
everything he did should have meant a
rams victory but it didn't because of
jared goff who we just talked about and
we'll talk about more coming up
i mean this guy had five tackles he had
a sack he had four quarterback hits he
had a tackle for loss
he had a pass defense that was
intercepted he had a forced fumble that
led to a defensive touchdown i mean what
else do you want the guy to do
they started double and triple teaming
him to keep him out of the backfield
because he was
killing the 49ers play after play after
play
just an outstanding performance and you
know a lot of questions
that he was asked at the end of last
week about hey you haven't had any sacks
the last two weeks what's the deal
he answered that on sunday against the
49ers
yeah and uh one thing that he may have
done
six weeks ago when the 49ers beat the
rams after debo samuel had
uh 66 receiving yards and a touchdown he
was asked about donald was devos samuel
when he said who's that
so if he didn't know then he knows now
because samuel
who hadn't played in five weeks was
spectacular he's my player of the game
he was the offense for the 49ers
want to get this absolutely right here
where is it where is and i thought i had
the stats open of course i didn't had 11
catches for over 100 receiving yards
um didn't have any rushing attempts
usually he does there we go thank you
very much 133 yards he was clearly the
best player on offense
uh clearly the best player on either
side of the ball for the 49ers after
five weeks of not playing
and he took to twitter afterward and
tweeted a gif of aaron donald slamming
down his helmet
so uh uh yeah aaron donald knows who
debo samuel is now and and samuel
is a guy that the 49ers took early in
the second round of the 2014 draft when
they could have taken dk metcalf
and they took another receiver
early third round i wonder what they
would have done if if dk metcalf was
still on the board
and can you imagine if the 49ers had
come out
of the 2019 draft with debo samuel and
dk metcalf
that would be unbelievable mike and and
he is just an outstanding player and he
showed it again
and the funny thing is somebody
responded to his tweet about aaron
donald saying
it takes a really brave man to to put
that up
about aaron donald and he tweeted debo
ain't never feared a soul
on that gridiron or in real life and
he showed it i mean just an outstanding
performance and he shows you what he
means the 49ers had missed a few games
this season
he's a really good player mike and when
we start mentioning the best receivers
in the nfl we don't talk about him
very much but i think we need to start
if he can stay in the lineup i think
he's going to be one of those guys we do
talk about
it was jaylen heard of baylor taking
three picks after dk metcalf
by the 49ers uh instead of dk since he
was gone and heard hasn't done anything
yet he's been on injury reserve for the
last two years all right
a player who after further review uh
performed better
than you may have originally thought
shireen
well carrie hyder spent some time with
the cowboys over the last few years and
so i got to know him a little bit
i mean he was just a guy right he's a
jag and he didn't do very much
and he had 10 career sacks before this
year so that tells you exactly where he
was
he has seven and a half sacks this
season mike and he had two sacks
uh four tackles four quarterback hits a
fumble recovery they returned
14 yards against rams and just really
played well and he's played well i think
he has
four sacks over the last four weeks and
with nick bosa being out
and d ford is now not going to return
kyle shanahan said earlier
today he doesn't expect d4 to return so
with those guys out
carrie heider's getting his chance and i
think he's showing he can be a very
productive player for somebody
this year and into the future you know
and i
originally had jimmy ward as my guy we
gave him some props as uh defensive
player of the week
i'm gonna squeeze in some love for
raheem moster he had a touchdown for the
49ers he didn't have huge stats
but what really impressed me more than
anything else
there was a play where aaron donald got
a quick jump and blue passed
the offensive line of the 49ers and he
was
i believe going to end the life of nick
mullins
if raheem mostert hadn't intervened to
stop him
so that alone that alone deserves some
credit and gets mostar mentioned here
even though it wasn't a classic rahim
mostar huge game he was coming back
after missing several weeks due to
injury he's back as the starting running
back
but that play there kept nick mullins on
the field otherwise it would have been
cj beathard for the 49ers so i got to
give her he most of a little love
yeah absolutely mike and i think he he's
like the
like debo i talked about he really
changes that running game and another
guy we don't talk about either when when
we
go to mention really great running backs
but he's one of those guys and the 49ers
just seem to keep coming up with those
guys right jeff wilson has a big game
matt barida had a big game for him when
he was with the 49ers i mean it's just
running back after running back they
flip them in there and they do great
things and he's one of those guys
speaking of running backs the running
back for the rams had a game to forget
shireen
oh yes he did malcolm brown so
forgettable he didn't start the game
mike but
he played more snaps than any other
running back for the rams and that that
could
dwindle going into the next few games
because he had a really forgettable
game and 25 snaps he lost the fumble
early on the rams first series
and the 49ers turned it right back over
so it didn't lead to anything but he
ended up with three carries for four
four yards and two catches for 15 yards
cam akers ended up being the guy and you
might see him getting more snaps
more carries more action going forward
because cam akers played much better
than malcolm brown did
yeah sean mcvay really wants to do the
three-headed monster at running back and
have interchangeable parts like the
49ers do you
if if you can't trust one of the guys in
a given game
somebody else is going to get more
touches that's the football way they
don't keep going back to the guy who's
struggling they go with the guy who's
got the hot hand and cam makers
had the hot hand on sunday for me it's
jared goff and i don't need to spend a
lot of time on this three turnovers
the interception that he threw to
richard sherman
it's almost like richard sherman was the
intended receiver and
and i think it was jared goff sensing
the walls closing in
so he forced the ball before he was
ready but
i mean you're a professional quarterback
and you're making what 32 33 million a
year
this is not unfair criticism
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports